you
hello my name is Karen boarded with l8r
you encourage the 6th annual San Diego
PD you read Sasuke Wilson Brown go to
cinema speakeasy having trouble speaking
myself and she's going to be talking
about crowdfunding sure crowds what do I
said crowdfunding is a new methodology
for Phil for fundraising coils the idea
behind it is like a lot of the DIY
distribution environment is to
democratize the process and filmmaking
both from conception to production to
distribution leadership customers
funding comes in obviously the
fundraising heart it ties it nicely with
the marketing in the distribution and as
much as your funders you can become your
supporters and your new buyers or a few
fillers or whatever it's so specifically
what it is is that the concept is that
you you you harness to your community
and communities that would be interested
in your film to get micro donations or
sometimes lots of micro but donations
towards your production process with the
idea that they would then have some
sense of ownership in the film and
therefore buy into the film but
literally an awesome metaphorically when
they support it further in a nutshell
that's sort of what it is the main sites
that are working in it is indiegogo.com
and kickstarter com is also obviously
doing a lot of it
I know when agent stupid was one of the
very successful other examples yes
thanks to you guys I remember what
happens there's a number of examples the
most recent versus gents culvers driven
the documentary about the UFC fighter
jets calls are you eat or the reason it
was successful was when we raised a lot
of money through am at a time I think
was what 25 dozen so the right but also
the reason he was able to do that is
because he tapped into not just the film
community and not just like documentary
fans and not just his friends and family
but also the massive fan base around
before put out there fighting so that's
an example of a success because it was
sort of a cross marketed initiative and
it did very well he made his goal what
everybody nice do you have for a
beginning filmmaker that once will start
a Kickstarter account
I do a lot of strategy writing for this
very thing so I mean that the biggest
thing is to have your pitch down pat
really like a good pitch for the paddock
know what you're doing make sure it's a
strong story quite frankly and put it up
there and just there's a number of
strategies obviously we just basically
just make sure you're reaching your
community whether your potential
audience funders and not just your
friends and family let you start there
we need to quickly expand just your
friends get stuck up getting facebook
updates crank that would be the biggest
thing is happier your brand we're coming
down really strong you know
you